[Music]
you are the CEO of a large multinational
company your company has a hundred and
seventy billion dollars in revenue it
serves 1.2 billion customers and it
employs almost a million people but it's
not all good news for you
in the past few decades your company has
lost revenue and market share at pretty
alarming rates your home markets of
North America and Europe are the ones
that have been hit the hardest off that
only by growth in emerging markets like
Latin America and Africa but that's not
gonna be good enough you're the CEO of
this business what are you gonna do my
name is Sara Joyce and the organization
that I just described to you is the
Catholic Church the Catholic Church is a
company that I've always been interested
in I grew up in a Catholic household I
went to a Catholic school I even worked
as an altar server helping the priest
with mass on Sundays I did my grade 10
career speech about how women should be
priests thinking that I was going to
become one then my life went in a bit of
a different direction I became a
management consultant but it was only in
working and consulting for a few years
in marketing strategy that I became
interested in the church in a new way I
was helping clients with declining
revenue and declining market share
problems and I started wondering what if
I took the same common approach that I
was using on my clients and applied it
in an uncommon place the Catholic Church
what if I was the CEO of the church what
would I do but I get it the Catholic
Church is my thing it definitely might
not be yours on one hand you might not
be religious you might not be Catholic
you're wondering why you should care
about the church I get it on the other
hand maybe a really religious really
Catholic you think the church is sacred
not something to be turned around or
fixed I get that too but the beauty of
this exercise to me
is that it actually doesn't matter where
stand on the issue it's not really about
religion at all rather it's about taking
something that has typically not been
thought of with the consumer marketing
lens and just seeing what happens if we
start to think of it this way and so I
invite you to suspend disbelief and
indulge with me in this exercise of you
and I as Pope and CEO and of course it's
been a bit of a bumpy ride in getting to
the top of the church when I first
started thinking about this topic back
in November Pope Benedict was firmly in
place when I first delivered it in March
there was no Pope we had the first
resignation of the Pope in over 700
years and as I stand here today we have
Pope Francis the first pope from an
emerging market and hopefully signal of
positive change that is to come there
was a lot of really great press at the
time when this was all happening my
personal favorite from CBS News
look would that be our inspiration for
today so if we were the CEOs of the
church the first thing that we would do
is define the problem and in this case
define the problem as greater net losses
of existing customers in traditional
markets than any other major faith and
while that may sound like an unnecessary
mouthful there's a reason why I say it
like that this is a global complex
problem like any good CEO we're gonna
focus down and tackle it one issue at a
time starting here in the US it's our
home market it also happens to be the
one we have the best data on and so step
two we scan the industry and we say how
are our competitors doing
who's winning in this market and why and
when we grant grab data on religious
affiliation in the u.s. over the past
few decades we can see that the Catholic
affiliation has been relatively flat
hovering around 25 percent of the
population well that might not seem like
enough of cause for change what this
line hides is how the population base
has changed within that we've lost a lot
of existing customers and we're
benefiting here from immigration from
Latin America primarily from Mexico so
what about the Protestants when we grab
the data on them we see that they
actually have
worse than we do they were at 60% of the
population a few decades ago and they're
just about at 50 today so then what
about this one any ideas to the one
religion that's been eating our lunch I
think I heard it in there the religion
that's been winning is those who are
unaffiliated with religion or the nuns
as I will call them these nuns they they
may have been raised in in religion but
they've become unaffiliated with what
they were raised in without rejoining
with another faith and the next logical
question is who are these people and it
turns out when we ask ourselves this we
need to look no further than this room
this is the millennial generation 18 to
29 we have more choice more freedom
expression we don't need to do what our
parents did anymore and so as CEOs of
the church doesn't this seemed like a
logical intervention points to re-engage
with our millennial Catholics before
they become nuns and so we define our
target customer as the Millennial
Catholics 18 to 29 years old who were
raised Catholic but are currently not as
engaged as they used to be or as we
would like them to be and if you're with
me so far
then here comes the fun part what are we
gonna do about it I like to think about
customer engagement in three ways we
need to do something to get them into
the door we then need to do something
with them while they're here and we need
to do something that keeps them coming
back so let's go through each of these
to get them in the door this is the
Millennials we're talking about you
might think to turn to social media well
I find it extremely fascinating that the
Pope has a Twitter account with 2.4
million followers that celebrities and
athletes who are the key influencers for
this demographic are constantly tweeting
Thanksgiving thanks and praise and
appreciation to God even Jesus has his
own Twitter account
Twitter actually did a study last year
and found that some of the most popular
tweets in terms of the number of tweets
and retweets were those that had an
inspiring message about God talk about
meeting your customers where they are
and if social media is not enough maybe
another idea to get them in could be
direct outreach at some of you in the
room know there's a very famous target
campaign where they use the data that
they have to predict when someone might
be pregnant and then they sent targeted
mailings and coupons to those expectant
mothers on baby products well what if we
use the data that we had on our
demographic to predict when they might
be going through major life events when
they graduate college moved to a new
city start a new job just like the
expectant mothers were more receptive to
target in those moments wouldn't our
demographic be more receptive to us so
we've got them in the door now what are
we gonna do with them and I actually
don't think there's much you can do with
the mess the sacraments the homily or
the sacraments the the traditions
everything needs to remain the same the
church isn't gonna go for budging on
much of that but I do think there's an
opportunity to innovate the homily for
those of you who don't know the homily
is the five to 10 sometimes 15 20 30
minutes that the priest has to connect
the fundamental teachings of the church
to today's modern world some priests are
really good at this today the problem is
it's inconsistent I can't help but think
back to my family we would pile into the
minivan and we would drive for 25
minutes past our local parish to this
one particular parish to see this one
particular priest father Joe father Joe
was 6 feet tall he had long dark hair
and big booming voice he was funny and
charismatic when he spoke he walked
right up into the pews and interacted
with his audience he made you laugh he
made you cry
he made you laugh because you were
crying and that was kind of weird but
when you left you left feeling inspired
and uplifted and feeling everything that
I would want my congregation to feel if
I were the CEO so how do we hold all
priests up to the Father joe standard
I've come to realize that we can't
priests are called to serve they're not
recruited for their public speaking
abilities but there might be an
opportunity to help them out what about
hiring professional speakers to come in
every once in a while
what about hiring speech writers and
communication coaches and damn it when
we find a message that works
why not videotape it so we can share it
across the network don't make me drive
to father Joe bring father Joe and me
and so that brings me to my final point
how are we gonna keep them a CEOs of the
church we don't want our relationship
with our congregation to end when math
ends we want to give them something to
take with them into the week luckily
today we have mobile phones something
that is always with our target
demographic so what if we used a mobile
app to allow us to share content with
them allow them to share content with
one another we could have a prayer wall
we could create invites track rides
attendance we could even accept online
donations imagine there are apps like
this that exist
it's estimated that 10,000 parishes are
already using them what is the Catholic
Church waiting for why not become the
next one so hopefully by now you have
seen that an uncommon approach or a
common approach rather can work in even
the most uncommon place if I were the
CEO of the church I would go after the
millennial generation I would use social
media and direct outreach to bring them
in
I'd innovate the homily for them once
they're there and I would use a mobile
app to keep them coming back my next
steps are pretty clear I'm gonna try to
get this onto Pope Francis's desk but
what about all of you I haven't
forgotten about you what problem are you
facing what's going on in your industry
who are your customers and how are you
gonna optimize the experience for them
you are the CEO thank you
you
[Music]